منورنا من الرباط عامل النظافه محفوظ لحفر
محفوظ يسعد صباحك شكرا على تواجدك معانا
اهلا بك صباح الخير
صباح النور
[موسيقى]
اجمل صوره رغم انه في الواقع ما تكون ربما
حياتها الواقعيه انت تحرص على توثيق
يومياتك يوميات عملك وبكل فخر بالاول شو
اللي دفعك انك توفي اليوميه
ااااه اول شيء انا يعني هذه
عمل ومن قوت اليوم ديالي وكذلك اللي كان
من وسط الرسائل بزاف لمن انك يمكن انك بدل
الحياه يمكن انا ما يكونش عندك ولا يكون
عملي وبسيط يمكن انك تطور الحياه ديالك
وتوصل بزاف ديال الاشياء الجميله في
الحياه ديالك انت شفت من خلال شباب اللي
تتابعوك وانت عندك الاف المتابعين على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي 300,000 على
فيسبوك 100,000 على الانستغرام و77,000
على يوتيوب توقعت كل هال- هالتاثير على
الشباب
هي مده طويله مش انا قدام وكان الى من دخل
المسجد يعني
يعني الشيء اللي كنت دائما نكون بزاف ديال
الشباب يعني يكون من الاستفاده ماشي
فيديوهات بدون فائده يعني الناس اللي
كيكون متجباني انهم يستفيدوا مني وهذا
الشيء اللي كان اللي كان حصل الان يعني
بزاف بهم على الشارع الحياه
يعني الحمد لله قال ناس يعني يمكن ان نكون
انا اول نظافه يمكن في العالم العربي اللي
كيف
بزاف يعني فيديوهات
وكذلك وصلوني مساج
[موسيقى]
المزيد ان شاء الله حكينا موسيقى الفنان
يعني قام قفل المجال ديال التاوي ويعني
الناس يعني تقدر من الدري اللي هو بسيط
وعلى قد الحال
يقدر انه يطول الحياه دياله امكانيه بسيطه
لكن
والله ما عندك طموح في الموسيقى
لا احد فنانين المغرب مش حابب تسمعنا
وبركه تكون فرصه لك اي جهه تتبناك اليوم
على الهواء مباشره
[موسيقى]
ادريني يا لميمه
تنسى القمار
كله صحابي وحبابي
اه ياني احياني
زمان راعياني
[تصفيق]
احبابي من عدياني
اعذريني يا لميمه
لسان ودموعك باسبان ابي
ان تخطيني تمشي القيمه كله صحابي واحبابي
طيب
خلص الوقت شكرا جزيلا لك تحياتنا لك قولي
شجاعتك شكرا